البيت الابيض يدعو جميع الاطراف الى
احتواء التصعيد في غزه ونتنياهو يتوعد
جميع الجبهات
قتلى بينهم زير فرنسي بسلاح مهاجم حاول
الوصول الى معبد الغريبه اليهودي في جربه
تونسي
وزير الخارجيه المصريه تهم اثيوبيا ويقول
ان افكارها منعت التوصل لاتفاق بشان سد
النهضه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره لاهم الانباء من
العربيه دعا البيت الابيض الى احتواء
التصعيد في غزه مدافعا في الوقت نفسه عما
سماه حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها من
الهجمات الصاروخيه التي تشنها جماعات
ارهابيه على حد تعبير واكد متحدث باسم
البيت الابيض التزام الولايات المتحده
الراسخ اتجاه اسرائيل بحقها في حمايه
نفسها وجاء الموقف الامريكي بعد اطلاق
الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله ضد حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
العمليه الاسرائيليه التي اسفرت عن مقتل
ثلاثه من ابرز قاده سرايا القدس ذراع
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في قطاع
غزه تسببت ايضا في مقتل اشخاص اخرين من
عائلات وجيران القاده المستهدفين كانت
عنيفه وتم خلالها استخدام القوه بشكل مفرط
بحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي شاركت 40 طائره
اسرائيليه في هذه الغاره على غزه كما ان
التخطيط للعمليه بدا منذ شهر رمضان الماضي
حيث كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يقصد تحركات
قيادات الجهات
قال انه اصدر تعليماته للاجهزه الامنيه
بالتصعيد وعلى اكثر من جبهه اذا لزم الامر
واشار خلال مؤتمر عقب اجتماع الحكومه
المصغره الى ان اي تصعيد من غزه سيقابل
برد
ساحقسون
اصدرت تعليمات بالاستعداد للتصعيد ربما
على اكثر من جبهه يجب ان نوضح لاعدائنا ان
اي تصعيد من جانبهم سيقابل برد ساحق اتفهم
الرغبه في استهداف هؤلاء فورا لكن علينا
التمهل في استخدام القوه كتحذير اخير
نتصرف دائما ضد اولئك الذين يسعون الى
القضاء علينا ولكن في وقت مناسب لنا
اما وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
فشدد على ان العمليه العسكريه في غزه
اثبتت قوه المنظومه الامنيه وكذا ان
اسرائيل مصممه على احباط اي تهديد وجاهزه
لاي سيناريو بما فيه معركه طويله
ثوره اطلاق الصواريخ على اسرائيل قبل نحو
اسبوع استعد الجهاز الامني للتعامل مع
قاده الجهاد في غزه وقمنا باستهدافهم خلال
عمليه سريعه وخاطفه من جربنا فهم قوه
اسرائيل وقوه النظام الامني نحن مصممون
على احباط اي تهديد والعمل ضد اولئك الذين
يحاولون الحاق الاذى
بنامي وفي اتصال مع الوسطاء اخبرت اسرائيل
كلا من مصر وقوات اليونيفيل العامله جنوب
لبنان بانها سترد بشكل راضع على اي هجمات
عسكريه تنطلق من قطاع غزه او لبنان نقلت
القناه الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه ون تل
ابيب هددت في الاتصالات التي اجرت ها مع
الوسطاء حركه حماس في قطاع غزه وحزب الله
في لبنان برد رادع فيما لو قرر الرد على
هجماتها الاخيره على قطاع غزه
عربت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن استنكار
واشنطن لهجوم مدينه جربه بجنوب تونس والذي
اسفل عن سقوط عدد من القتلى والجرحى اشيده
بتحرك السريع لقوات الامن التونسيه وكانت
وزاره الداخليه التونسيه اعلنت ان احد
عناصر الحرس التابع للمركز البحري للحرس
الوطني بجزيره جربه اقدم على قتل زميله
باستعمال سلاح الفردي والاستيلاء على
الذخيره ثم حاول الوصول الى محيط معبد
الغريبه اليهودي وعمد الى اطلاق النار
بصفه عشوائيه على الوحدات الامنيه
المتمركزه بالمكان والتي تصدت له ومنعته
من الوصول الى المعبد ورده قتيلا واوضحت
الداخليه ان العمليه اسفلت عن مقتل رجل
يامن واصابه خمسه باصابات متفاوته الخطوره
كما قتل اثنان من الزوار وهما تونسي
وفرنسي مصيبه اربعه اخرون بجروح متفاوته
تم نقلهم الى المستشفى لتلقي العلاج
داخليه التونسيه فتحت تحقيقا في الحادث
لكشف الملابسات ومعرفه الدوافع
قال وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري ان
تعنط اثيوبيا وافكارها التطبيق السياده
لافكارها لتطبيق السياده على مورد مائي
مشترك عابر للدوله منع الوصول لاتفاق بشد
بشان سد النهضه واكد شكري خلال تصريحات
تلفزيونيه من تشاد ان مصر تراعي المصالح
الاقتصاديه الاثيوبيه بما يحمل امن المائي
لمصر والسودان مضيفا بان بلاده ستواصل
الحديث مع شركاء الدوليين في ملف السد
الاثيوبي لقدرتهم على التاثير وانها في
الوقت ذاته لن تسمح بتعرض شعبها لاي ضرر
في ملف
السد الاثيوبي
في السودان تخطت الازمه يومها الرابع
والعشرين وسط استمرار لجهود انهاء الصراع
والوصول الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار غياب
ارضيه للتفاهم ترك الوضع على حاله لتتجدد
الاشتباكات وتتواصل في حصد الضحايا في اخر
احصاء لعدد الضحايا كشفت منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان عدد القتلى جراء الاشتباكات
في السودان وصل الى 640 بينهم مدنيون كما
ان القتال ادى الى عصابه ما يزيد على
5100 شخص نقلا عن المنظمه
وهو في سياق متصل اعلنت المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره عن تضاعف عدد النازحين داخل
السودان ليصل الى اكثر من 700 الف في ظل
استمرار القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع نتعرف على ابرز وجهات النازحين في
السودان
صامده واخرى كاجراحهم يستغيث السودانيون
من ويلات النزوح واللجوء داخليا وضع
انساني كارثي وحاجه ماسه للخدمه الطارئه
اما الطريق الى دول الجوار فمحفوف
بالمتاعب وكلاهما مشقه ومعاناه في الوصول
بسلام منظمه الهجره الدوليه اكدت ان عدد
النازحين في الداخل تضاعف خلال اسبوع من
300 واربعين الفا الى اكثر من 700 الف اما
اجمالي الاحصاءات منذ بدء المعارك بلغ
قرابه ثلاثه ملايين وسبعمائه الف مشرد في
حين رصدت المنظمات الامميه 100,000 من
لاجئي الخارج مع توقعات بوصولهم الى 800
الف وعن القتلى فتخطى عددهم حاجز السبع
مئه وخمسين شخصا ونحو خمسه الاف جريح
وبينما تناكف اعمده الدخان المتصاعد خيارا
النزوح وجد الفارون امنا في المدن البعيده
عن بؤر الصراع اذ يعاني اقليم دارفور وضعا
انسانيا خانقا في معسكرات نازحيه وكانت
ابرز وجهه الهاربين الداخليا واكثرها
هدوءا مدينه واد مدني في ولايه الجزيره
ومنها ينتقلون شرقا وجنوبا الى سنار وكسلا
والجدارف والنيل الازرق كما وجدوا في
الولايه الشماليه حصنا امنا من الاشتباكات
اما مدينه كوستي بولايه النيل الابيض فتعد
ثاني اكثر المدن ايواء للفرين من جحيم
الحرب
ولايات ما كان اختيارها بالنسبه للمدنيين
عبثيا وانما تكاتف السودانيين في محنه
بلادهم كان دليلا على تعاونهم بمبادره
الاهالي على فتح بيوتهم لاستقبال النازحين
اسراء الصغير العربيه
المعارك الدائره بين الجيش والدعم السريع
ادت الى ركود في الاسواق التجاريه في
ولايه جنوب دارفور غربيه السودان وتعد
الولايه المواطره لعدد من المناطق باقليم
دارفور وحتى الدول المجاوره
في اسواقهم ترى جماليتهم وبراءتهم وطيبتهم
هنا في نياله جنوب دارفور غربيه السودان
الاثار الاقتصاديه للاقتتال بين الجيش
والدعم السريع خلفت ركودا كبيرا لم يتوقعه
المنتجون منذ سنوات بعيده والله حركه
البيع يعني ما زي زمان الناس كلها شاده
يعني الناس امام ما في الحرب
الحرب شتت الناس كلها
المواصلات بقت بالف جنيه والمواصلات صعبه
في البيت انت بترقد تكون متقلقل تسمع صوت
السلاح 24 ساعه والذخيره وتعدني على ثاني
اكبر المدن في السودان المركز التجاري
الاضخم باقليم دارفور ونافذه عالميه للدول
المجاوره للبلاد
تهشم الامر فيها وادى الى توقف الحركه
التجاريه
باسواق الولايه اسعار زمان الشوال بتاعه
باميه بعشرين
الفرين 25 25 17
واي خدر نزل هبوط شديد يعني هذا السوق كان
يعج بالحركه اصبح اليوم شبه خالي اذ لا
يمكن لاحد ان يوقظه من نومه وسط اصوات
الرصاص التي تسمع كل يوم والله خساره
كبيره يعني يوم واحد ما بيتحمل لكن طبعا
الحرده امتدت هسه قال لنا 22 يوم بالنسبه
للحرب ده والناس طلعت يعني طلعت من من في
يدين ومن شيء وطرد من اموال ومن انفسهم
يعني خايفين بالنسبه لنفسهم يعني في بلد
تج
را عديده غياب الامن يعيده الى ايام توصف
بالمؤلمه
وصلت اولى طلائع الجسر الجوي السعودي الى
مطار بورتودان لمساعده شعب السوداني من
جهه اخرى اعلنت وزاره الدفاع السعوديه في
بيان لها عن تنفيذها لست رحلات اجلاب منذ
بدء عمليات الاجلال من السودان الى
المملكه كما ورد بيان وزاره الدفاع عن
بلوغ عدد من تم اجلائهم عبر طائرات القوات
الجويه السعوديه الى السعوديه نحو 530
شخصا بينهم سعوديون واخرون ينتمون ل 23
دوله
تستعد الى طائرات وطلائع الجسر الجوي
السعودي اللغاتي لمساعده الشعب السوداني
بالاقلاع عبر عديد من المساعدات التي سيتم
ارسالها عبر هذه الطائره العسكريه التي
ستحمل بعشره اطنان موزعه على عدد من
المساعدات الهوائيه والغذائيه والدوائيه
وتحمل على متنها ايضا فريق من مركز الملك
سلمان بالاضافه الى فريق حمايه سيذهب
مباشره الى مطار بورتسودان لانزال هذه
المساعدات مباشره كما انه سيكون هنالك
طائره اخرى ستقلع بعد ساعات من مطار
الرياض الى بورت السودان لانزال المساعدات
مباشره الى المطار السوداني سنتحدث اكثر
مع الدكتور سامر الجطيلي متحدث الرسمي
باسم مركز الملك سلمان للغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه دكتور حدثنا عن اولى طلائع هذا
الجسر وما تحميله من مساعدات
حياكم الله
تنطلق اول طائره يتم تحويلها تحميلها
حاليا وهي اول طائره من الجسر الجوي
انفاذا لتوجيهات سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين واولي عهدي الامين
بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه
للشعب السوداني الشقيق هذه الطائرات تحمل
حوالي عشر اطنان من المواد الغذائيه
والمواد الايوائيه وكذلك المواد الطبيه
والتي تمثل الحقيقه اهم الاحتياجات في هذه
المرحله سوف تتبع هذه الطائره طائره اخرى
اليوم وسوف يستمر هذا الجسر الجوي باذن
الله عز وجل حتى نصل الى مستهدفنا وحتى
نحقق توجيه السامي الكريم بايصال
المساعدات للاشقاء في السودان هذا اول
الخير اسال الله عز وجل التوفيق ونسال
الله عز وجل ان نكون على قدر هذه المهمه
الكبيره التي وليت لنا في مركز الملك
سلمان الشكر الجزيل لوزاره الدفاع للقوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه والتي الحقيقه
تقوم الان مشكوره بهذا الجسر الجوي نسعى
باذن الله عز وجل لتحقيق اثر وصناعه
الحقيق تغيير في حياه المحتاجين في هذه
المرحله من الازمه والصراع في السودان
شكرا جزيلا الدكتور اذا انت تستعد هذه
الطائره الى الاقلاع بعد قليل وهي هذه
الطائره ستحمل هذه
المساعده الواقعه بين بورتسودان الى
الخرطوم على ان تستمر هذه العمليه خلال
الايام القادمه وسط حمله شعبيه نودي لها
هنا بالسعوديه للتبرع على ان تستمر هذه
الى ايام واسابيع قادمه وان تصل الى كافه
الولايات السودانيه
التي تحتاج هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل عبد
المحسن الحربي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
الرياض
وكما تشاهدون على عواجل العربيه تجدد قصف
الطيران العسكري لمواقع في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وسنوافيكم بالمزيد من
التفاصيل تباعا عبر شاشه العربيه ايضا في
هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
السعوديه تعلن استئنافه عمل بعثتها
دبلوماسيه في سوريا
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت الخارجيه سعوديه
استئناف عمل بعثه دبلوماسيه في الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه فيما ذكرت انه ياتي حرصا
على لساني في تطوير العمل العربي المشترك
وتعزيز الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه وكذلك
تنفيذه لقرار الجامعه العربيه الاخير بشان
عوده سوريا لانشطتها واجتماعاتها
وبالاضافه الى الهيئات والمنظمات اتابع
لها
استقبل الدكتور رشاد محمد العليمي رئيس
مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني سفيره سعودي
محمد سعيد الجابر ونقش طرفان خلال اللقاء
جهود وساطه المملكه لتجديد الهدنه وتخفيف
المعاناه الانسانيه ووقف اطلاق النار وفرص
التوصل الى حل سياسي شامل في اليمن برعايه
الامم المتحده
قال سكرتيره مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكرانيه الاكسي داني لوف ان قوتك لم
تتبنى حتى الان الخطه النهائيه للهجوم
المضاد حيث يتم تعديلها باستمرار حسب
تطورات الاحداث وقال دانيلاو ان لدى
اوكرانيا عده خيارات وجميعها قيد الدراسه
وحسب الظروف سيتم اتخاذ القرارات وكان
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
صرح في وقت سابق بان بلاده مستعده للهجوم
المضاد وان القوات تنتظر قرار القياده
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه قال قائد قوات
فاجناري ان قواته تقدمت في المحور الغربي
لبخموت وسيطرت على 180 مترا مربعا في
العمق مؤسس فاجنخ جوما على المسؤولين
الروس هذه المره تجاوز الدفاع الروسيه
ووزيرها
سهام اتهاماته الى الكرم مباشره
بقدرته على الدفاع عن البلاد في وقت تستعد
اوكرانيا لهجوم مضاد
كان هذا اليوم الموعود للاستيلاء على
باقمه الاوكرانيه رمزيه النصر في يوم
النصر وفقا لقائد قوات باجنر والقياده
الروسيه ايضا لكنه تحول الى اعنف هجوم
يشنه
على قيادات الكريم
لا يجب ان يموت الجندي بسبب الغباء المطلق
للقياده في موسكو الجنرالات والضباط على
الارض ملزمون بتنفيذ هذا الغباء لان
الاوامر التي تصلهم من الاعلى هي اجراميه
بكل ما تحمله الكلمه من معنى غباء القياده
هذا ليس الاحتراف الوحيد الذي كشفه زعيم
قوات فاجنر فالرجل رفع من سقف حربه مع
رجال الكرملين حددت تشكيك بقدره الحكومه
الروسيه في الدفاع عن البلاد
اوكرانيا تضرب المناطق الحدوديه الروسيه
بنجاح لماذا الدوله الروسيه غير قادره على
الدفاع عن البلاد
جنرالات الكريميلين كانوا مشغولين بنصب
المكائد بدلا من القتال يقول بريكوجين امر
انعكس على جبهات القتال ودفعت جنود الروس
الى الفرار من ساحات المعارك جبن مبطن
للجيش تهمهم به طبخ كما كان يطلق عليه
فوفقا للرجل فان وحده عسكريه روسيه فرت
مؤخرا من مواقعها قرب باخموت ما جعلت جبهه
مكشوفه على خطوط القتال التي تتمركز فيه
قواته كما لم تتلقى مجموعته سوى عشره
بالمئه من الذخيره اللازمه للقتال امر
اعتبره الرجل جريمه لتدمير الشعب الروسي
ايام وتنسحب فاجنر من تخوم باخموت
فحتى بوتين مخدوع من قبل جنرالاته في
الحمله العسكريه في اوكرانيا خداع قال
انهم سيدفعون ثمنه على يد القائد او الشعب
الروسي اذا خسر الحرب رائد المصطفى
العربيه
وعلى الرغم من هذه الاتهامات المتبادله
احتفلت روسيا بيوم النصر في اجواء وصفت
بانها صامته حيث غاب عن العرض اهم وابرز
الاسلحه التي طالما كانت حاضره في السنوات
السابقه ولا تغيب عن الساحه الحمراء
حضر العسكر وغابت عضلات روسيا العسكريه في
يوم النصر مشهد يختلف عن سابقه
عرض يوم النصر الروسي من دون دبابات ولا
انظمه دفاع جوي مقاتلات سلاح الجو غابت عن
سماء الساحه الحمراء كما غابت ايضا
الصواريخ بعيده المدى باستثناء صاروخ يارس
الحفل لم يدم سوى اربعين دقيقه صخب اقل
وهدوء اكثر بل وصمتم كما وصفته صحف غربيه
حتى في مدن اخرى الغيت الاحتفالات
بدا واضحا ان قلقا يسيطر على الحفل قلق قد
ياتي محملا بمسيرات كما وقع قبل ايام حين
وصلت مباني الكرملين وهذا ما يفسر انتشار
هذه القوه المدججه باسلحه مضاده للمسيرات
على اسطح مباني محيطه بالساحه الحمراء
[موسيقى]
التاسع من مايو لم ياتي بجديد ميدانيا كي
يضيفه الرئيس بوتين في خطابه فلا باخمت
سقطت كما كان يشاع ولا الغرب اوقف مساعدته
لكييف بل اعلن البنتا عن مساعدات جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليار و200 مليون دولار
اليوم حضارتنا مره اخرى تشهد نقطه تحول
حاسمه وتندلع حرب حقيقيه مره اخرى ضد
وطننا لكننا قومنا الارهاب الدولي
على بعد 2200 كيلومتر من موسكو تمت دعوات
اوروبيه لعدم الخشيه من استعراض بوتين
لقوته المستشار الالماني اولى فشولز قال
ان الاستعراض يجب الا يرهب الاتحاد
الاوروبي حثا الاتحاد على الاستمرار
الحازم في دعمه لاوكرانيا مهما طال الامر
تعد الانتخابات التركيه للعام 2023 فاصله
في الحياه السياسيه التركيه والمسار الذي
ستتخذه البلاد يحال فوز او خساره الرئيس
اردوغان
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه في 2023 انتخابات
مختلفه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا هي
المره الاولى التي يواجهوا فيها اردوغان
تحالفا يضم سته احزاب معارضه بينها حزباني
كبيران كما انها ليست منافسه تقليديه بين
ائتلافين حاكم ومعارض بقدر ما هي صراع على
تحديد هويه تركيا في قرنها الثاني ومفترق
طريق ستسلكه البلاد باردوغان او بدونه
سواء كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه الثامنه والعشرين تحظى باهميه
واحده حيث تاتي بعد مرور 100 عام على
تاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الطريق الذي ستنتهي به هذه الانتخابات في
حال فاز فيها اردوغان هو طريق قرن جديد
بوعود كبيره من قبل الرئيس التركي وفرصه
لتثبيت مشروعه السياسي اما خساره اردوغان
للرئاسه فقد تعني حقبه جديده داخليا
دستورا واصلاحات جديده وهو ما تساله
المعارضه من خلال الاطاحه باردوغان بهدف
دخول حقبه جديده تبدا بالتراجع عن سياساته
داخليا اي منعطف تسلكه الانتخابات قد يعني
تغيرات توجهات تركيا الخارجيه خاصه ان
الدوره والتاثير التركيه في الشؤون
الدوليه يمثل تحديا للمعارضه فهو شهاده
على انجازات اردوغان عقدان كانت الفتره
الاخيره الاصعب فيهما فقد شهدت فيها تركيا
متغيرات عده اقتصاديه على راسها التضخم
وكذلك كوارث طبيعيه زلزال كان بمثابه
اختبار للرئيس التركي لذا فان ما ستقرره
صناديق الاقتراع لن يتعلق فقط بمن سيحكم
لكن بكيفيه الحكم والمسار الاقتصادي الذي
سيسلكه الفائز وسياساته داخليا او خارجيا
[موسيقى]
فالختام هذا تذكير بابرز العالم
البيت الابيض يدعو جميع الاطراف الى
احتواء التصعيد في غزه ونتنياهو يتوعد
جميع الجبهات
قتلى بينهم زير فرنسي بسلاح مهاجم حاول
الوصول الى معبد الغريبه اليهودي في جربه
التونسيه
ووزير الخارجيه المصريه تهم اثيوبيا ويقول
ان افكارها منعت التوصل للاتفاق بشان سد
النحو
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات